what does somebody mean when they refer
to the converse inverse or
contrapositive of a statement take a
simple statement about no not that no
way back to I like that one
bikes have two wheels logical thinkers
that you and I are we can see that this
means everything that's a bike has two
wheels the logical structure is for all
X X is a bike implies X has two wheels
let's write that symbolically that's
first-order logic but we can just
simplify that even further with the two
propositions if you got a blank look on
your face or your eyes are glazing over
right now go back and check out my logic
and language series you can play with
that statement first invert it the
inverse of if it's a bike then it has
two wheels is if it's not a bike then it
does not have two wheels the inverse of
a statement isn't necessarily true in
this case there are two wheeled objects
that are not bikes the converse of if
it's a bike then it has two wheels
switches the terms so we end up with if
it has two wheels then it's a bike the
converse may be true if the original is
true but it isn't necessarily but notice
that the converse will be true if the
inverse is true think about that the
inverse negated both propositions and
the converse switched both propositions
there's also a contrapositive with
switching and negation going on for our
original statement if it's a bike then
it has two wheels the contrapositive is
if it's not two-wheeled then it's not a
bike looks like that's true so long as
the original was it's not good logic if
we can't abstract these structures to
other instances
using any two propositions a and B where
a implies B we can get to the inverse
the converse and the contrapositive this
way
something to notice if you want to get
even more playful with your logic is
that you can use the concepts
recursively on themselves what I mean is
for example the inverse isn't just the
inverse of the statement it's also the
converse of the contrapositive because
it switches the two propositions around
and the contrapositive isn't just the
contrapositive it's also the converse of
the inverse this is possible because
every statement can be reevaluated just
like the original they're not inherently
inverses or con versus or contra
positives they're just statements
they're those things in relation to each
other you'll find that people fumble
with these terms or use them in
precisely so take this first step to
straighten out for yourself the
relationship between a statement and the
ways it can be twisted up